.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO MY OPEN.
EVERY DAY IN THIS COUNTRY THE
GOVERNMENT UNDER JOE BIDEN OR
WHOEVER IS RUNNING THE JOINT
INFRINGES MORE AND MORE ON OUR
FREEDOM, PUSHING AMERICANS
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE EDGE.
THE LATEST, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES INSTRUCTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI TO ADDRESS THREATS
AGAINST SCHOOL BOARDS AND
TEACHERS OVER MASKS AND CRITICAL
RACE THEORY SAYING THOSE THREATS
SHOULD BE DISCOURAGED AND
PROSECUTED.
IT READS CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS DON'T EXTEND TO
EFFORTS TO INTIMIDATE
INDIVIDUALS OVER THEIR VIEWS.
THE CONSTITUTION PROTECTS ACTION
AND SPEECH WHERE INDIVIDUALS
SEEK A REDRESS OF THEIR
GRIEVANCE.
NOT YOU AG ATTEMPTS TO REMOVE
THAT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IF YOU
ARE A PARENT CONCERNED ABOUT NOW
YOUR CHILD IS BEING TAUGHT.
IT'S OKAY TO FOLLOW A U.S.
SENATOR INTO A BATHROOM AND
THREAT ONTO TAKE HER OUT OF
OFFICE.
IT'S OKAY FOR BLACK LIVES MATTER
RIOTERS TO INTIMIDATE AND BURN
DOWN OUR BUSINESSES.
BUT MAMA, DON'T THINK ABOUT
OBJECTING TO THE IDEOLOGICAL
RACIAL HATRED BEING HOISTED ON
THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
THIS IS VIEWPOINT
DISCRIMINATION.
IT RESTRICTS SPEECH ON A GIVEN
SUBJECT MATTER.
WITH LIMITED EXCEPTIONS, THE
GOVERNMENT CANNOT PICK AND
CHOOSE WHAT SPIECHES ACCEPTABLE
AND WHAT WILL BE SEEN AS
THREATENING.
THE SINGLING OUT OF A PARTICULAR
OPINION IS VIEW POINT
DISCRIMINATION.
THE CONSTITUTION AND SUPREME
COURT DISAGREE THAT EVEN SHADE
SPEECH IS PROTEXTED THOUGH I'M
NOT SUGGESTING THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
BUT THE LEFT IS ALL IN.
>> THEY TOOK OUR SCHOOL BOARDS
HOSTAGE LIKE A BUNCH OF
SCREAMING MANIACS.
JUDGE JEANINE: NOWHERE DOES THIS
CRONY OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND WHO YOU MAY
RECALL BARACK OBAMA WANTED TO
PUT ON THE SUPREME COURT,
DESCRIBED AS A MODERATE.
DEFINE INTIMIDATION?
>> PARENTS WAITING SOMETIMES FOR
HOURS TO SPEAK AT A LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY OR THE MASKING OF THEIR
STUDENTS, THE MASKING OF YOUNG
CHILDREN, IS THAT HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION.
>> SPIRITED DEBATE IS A HALLMARK
OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> IT DOESN'T DEFINE THOSE TERMS
NOR DOES IT DEFINE HARASSMENT OR
INTIMIDATION.
JUDGE JEANINE: IS IT REASONABLE
FOR A SCHOOL TEACHER TO FEEL
INTIMIDATED IF A PARENT GOES TO
A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING AND SAYS
TEACHERS SHOULD NOT BE TEACHING
CRT?
IS THAT ENOUGH FOR THE FBI TO
MAKE A VISIT TO YOUR HOME?
HOW IS IT THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS ARE THE VICTIMS IN ALL
THIS.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN MICROPHONES WHERE
PARENTS ARE EXPRESSING THEIR
GRIEVANCES.
IT'S THE PARENTS PAYING THEIR
SALARY AND THE PARENTS HAVE A
VESTED INTEREST IN THEIR OWN
CHILDREN.
IF A PARENT COMPLAINS ABOUT
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS NOT
REOPENING THE SCHOOLS, THE BOARD
MEMBERS SAY THEY WILL F THEM UP.
I'M NOT HEARING THE TO BE
GENERAL SAYING ANY THREATS WON'T
BE TOLL RATED OR WE'LL SEND THE
FBI TO SCHOOL BOARD HOMES OR
TEACHERS HOMES.
NO.
BECAUSE HE'S NOTHING MORE THAN A
POLITICAL HACK FOLLOWING ON THE
BIDEN AGENDA WHICH ALWAYS MONEY
MAKER FOR HIS DAUGHTER AND SON
IN LAW WHOSE.
MERRICK GARLAND BEFORE YOU SIC
YOUR AGENTS ON PARENTS.
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT THEIR
SAYING WITH PARENTS?
>> IF YOU WANT TO COME TALK TO
ME ABOUT HOW I'M NOT DOING A
GOOD ENOUGH JOB IN DISTANCE
LEARNING?
DARE THEM TO COME AT ME.
>> YOU GOING TO CALL ME OUT?
I'M GOING TO F YOU UP.
>> THEY WANT THEIR BABYSITTERS
BACK.
JUDGE JEANINE: WANT TO RE-ASSESS
WHO THE VICTIMS REALLY ARE?
NO, YOU ALREADY DECIDED WHO TO
DEMONIZE.
IN THE COMING DAYS THE DOJ WILL
ANNOUNCE A SERIES OF MEASURES TO
ASSESS THE RISE IN CRIMINAL
CONDUCT.
WAIT, YOU MEAN THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARD'S ASSOCIATION SEND
A LETTER TO YOU TO TEE UP THE
NEED TO CATEGORIZE PARENTS AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS?
AND NOT YOU FBI TONIGHT MIDDLE
OF LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS?
HOW ABOUT THE MILLIONS OF
PARENTS WHO WERE UNABLE TO WORK
BECAUSE THE TEACHERS DECIDE THEY
WEREN'T GOING TO TEACH YOUR
CHILDREN.
HOW ABOUT IF THEY WRITE A LETTER
TO YOU SAYING THEY FEEL
THREATENED EVERY TIME STHEF
APPEAR BEFORE A SCHOOL BOARD.
AND WHY THE FBI?
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
JURISDICTION OF ISSUES OWN A
LOCAL LEVEL.
AND CALLING A PARENT A DOMESTIC
TAIRN RIFT DOESN'T CHANGE A DARN
THING.
THEY HAVE NO JURISDICTION.
SINCE WHEN DOES THE FBI, THE
ESTEEMED AGENCY WHERE EVERY
AGENT IS SPECIAL.
THERE ARE NO AGENTS.
ONLY SPECIAL AGENTS.
SINCE WHEN DO THEY HANDLE
THREATS ON A LOCAL LEVEL UNTIL
THESE AREN'T NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES.
THE LOCAL POLICE, THE SHERIFF,
THE D.A., THEY DO THIS EVERY
DAY.
DOESN'T THE FBI HAVE BETTER
THINGS TO DO LIKE FOLLOW UP
LEADS, THE PARKLAND SHOOTING
CASE.
THE LARRY NASSAR GIRLS OLYMPICS
CASE HIGHLIGHTING THE FBI.
MAYBE THEY WERE TOO BUSY ON
POLITICAL PROSECUTION.
THEY KNOW ALL THE CHARACTERS AND
THE PROCLIVITIES TO HANDLE THESE
CASES.
I GUESS I FORGOT.
YOU WASHINGTON TIMES WANTS TO
DEFUNDS THE POLICE.
YOU WANT TO GET RID OF THEM NOT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE POLICE,
BUT BECAUSE YOU WANT A FEDERAL
POLICE FORCE, YOU AND YOUR
POLITICAL FRIENDS CAN CONTROL.
THIS ACTION BY AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL NO LESS IS FEDERAL
OVERREACH DESIGNED TO SILENCE
PARENTS, ACCEPT AN IDEOLOGY,
FOREIGN AND UNACCEPTABLE TO THEM
AND CALL THEM AND CATEGORIZE
THEM AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
AND WORST IT'S DESIGNED
TERRORIZE PARENTS AND STOP THEM
FROM VOICING THEIR CONCERNS.
FOLKS, ITS MANY ALL PART OF THE
MARXIST AGENDA.
SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS, FAMILY IS NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT UNIT, THE GOVERNMENT
IS.
THEY IMPOSED POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS ON OUR FREE SPEECH
WITH THE CONSEQUENCE OF BEING
CANCELED.
IF IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE SPEECH TO
THEM, THE NEXT STEP IS SOUTH
LOOKING OUR SPEECH JUST AS THEY
DO IN EUROPE.
HERE HIS AN EXAMPLE.
CNN'S DON LEMON.
>> WHAT IS POSTED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SHOULD BE TRUE.
IF IT'S NOT TRUE IT SHOULD BE
TAKEN DOWN.
IF IT'S NOT TRUE, DON'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PUT IT UP THERE.
HAVE THEM FACE CONSEQUENCES.
JUDGE JEANINE: MORE PUNISHMENT
FOR DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT.
THIS IS ALL VERY SERIOUS, FOLKS.
IT'S ONE THING TO SET STANDARDS.
ITS MANY ANOTHER THING TO
THREATEN PARENTS.
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER.
IT'S TIME TO TAKE YOUR KIDS OUT
OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
NO MATTER WHAT CLUELESS JOE SAYS
ABOUT CARING.
ANYONE WHO HAS KIDS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAS ALREADY LOST A YEAR
TO TWO YEARS OF TEACHERS BEING
PAID TO SIT AT HOME WHILE YOU DO
YOUR WORK.
YOU HAVE ALREADY LOST TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND
VOYAGE SCHOOLS.
THEY LOST OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
KEPT TEACHING.
ON TOP OF THAT THEY WANT TO
TERRORIZE YOU AND SHUT YOU UP.
IT'S TIME YOUR SCHOOL TAXES
FOLLOW YOUR CHILD.
IT'S NOTE SMART TO POKE MAMA
BEAR WHEN NICE PROTECTING HER
CUBS.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
MA